welcome everyone the government's daily
briefing I'm joined today by the chief
executive of the NHS Simon Stephens and
the deputy chief medical officer
Jenny Harris I'd like to update you all
on the facts are on the spread of
covered 19 and the steps that we are
taking in the battle against the corona
virus one hundred and thirteen thousand
seven hundred and seventy seven people
have now been tested for the virus of
those fourteen thousand five hundred and
forty three have tested positive an
increase in the last day of two thousand
eight hundred and eighty five the best
scientific analysis now is that the rate
of infection has been doubling every
three to four days and of those who have
contracted the virus seven hundred and
fifty-nine have sadly died our thoughts
and prayers over the families of those
who have passed away
these figures are a powerful reminder of
the need for all of us to act we need to
slow the spread of the virus and
strengthen the NHS's ability to protect
us all strict social distancing measures
have been put in place to restrict the
spread of covered 19 so fewer people
should need hospital treatment at any
one time the measures that we've put in
place for the scientific and medical
advice and are designed to reduce the
rate of infection and as well as acting
to slow the spread of the virus
we're also acting to strengthen the NHS
we're expanding the number of beds
available for new patients we're
increasing the number of staff in our
hospitals and we're also investing in
life-saving equipment for those with
severe symptoms to give people the care
they need when they need it most I'd
like to thank all those involved in this
effort to reinforce the front line in
the battle against the virus the
military personnel who are helping to
fit out the new Hospital in East London
and are helping to distribute personal
protective equipment the amazing doctors
nurses and support staff in our NHS
those in manufacturing who've risen to
the challenge of producing new
ventilators and the hundreds of
thousands who volunteered to help in
innumerable ways this is a United
national effort and the spirit of
selflessness shown by so many is truly
inspiring and this virus of course
affects us all as you no doubt already
aware the Prime Minister has coronavirus
and is self isolating at home in Downing
Street he began experiencing mild
symptoms yesterday afternoon and was
tested on the advice of England's chief
medical officer professor Chris Witte
the Prime Minister is continuing to lead
the government's response to coronavirus
chairing meetings and communicating with
key members of his team through
videoconferencing and earlier today the
Prime Minister led the effort in
launching our latest front in the fight
against coffered 19 today I can announce
that the Prime Minister has brought
together businesses research institutes
and universities in a new alliance to
boost testing capacity for frontline
workers increasing our testing capacity
is absolutely crucial in our response to
and our fight against coronavirus this
is a particular priority for those who
work in the health and social care
sector and are working so hard to keep
us all safe this will be antigen testing
testing whether people currently have
the disease so that our health and
social care workers can have security in
the knowledge that they are safe to
return to work if their test is negative
these tests will be trial for people on
the frontline starting immediately
with hundreds to take place by the end
of the weekend dramatically scaling up
next week and of course protecting our
frontline workers is at the forefront of
everyone's minds at the moment last
night millions of people paid a
fantastic tribute to the heroes and
heroines of the NHS when they stepped
outside their front doors and clapped
our carers and alongside those in health
and social care I also want to thank
those who work in food production and
retail those who work for the Royal Mail
and public transport our teachers and
our social workers they all deserve our
gratitude
and having talked to trade union and
business leaders civil servants and
public spirited volunteers and of course
ministers in the devolved
administration's in Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland in recent days I want
to record my admiration for the national
solidarity being shown in the fight
against this disease all of us can
support our NHS by continuing to follow
the guidance to stay at home to protect
our NHS and to save lives and I'll now
turn to the chief executive of the NHS
Silas Stevens Simon thank you Michael
today over 6200 confirmed positive
coronavirus patients are in hospital
across England and we know that number
is only bound to rise over the coming
days that's why as Michael says it is so
important that everybody follows the
medical advice to stay at home and in so
doing save lives but it's also why the
NHS is making an extraordinary effort
right across this country to ensure that
we have care for those patients who need
the looking after from coronavirus
that's why NHS staff are pulling out all
the stops in an unprecedented response
to this global health emergency as of
today across England we have
reconfigured Hospital services so that
33,000 hospital beds are available to
treat further coronavirus patients it's
also why we are taking the extraordinary
action to build new hospitals in very
short order starting with the NHS
Nightingale Hospital in East London and
today because this is a problem of
course not just confined to London but
across the whole country I have given
the go-ahead to the building of to
further of these NHS Nightingale
hospitals beginning at the Birmingham
National Exhibition Centre and the
Manchester central Convention Centre
with further such hospitals to follow in
doing that I obviously want to pay
tribute to the contribution not just of
NHS staff but the support that we're
getting from volunteers from the Armed
Forces from
social care from all of our partners it
is remarkable I think that in just the
last two weeks we've seen 18,000 doctors
and nurses return to practice on the
General Medical Council and the nursing
Medical Council registers answering the
call to arms and it was therefore very
gratifying for our staff across the NHS
to see this remarkable outpouring in the
clap for carers last night for many
nurses coming home from a day at
hospital or for other staff returning to
start again for the nightshift it will
have meant an enormous amount to know
that the whole country is behind them
but the best way we can show that
support of course is actually by doing
what it will take to reduce the rate of
infection because even simple actions
following this advice will save lives